[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a este especial
deportivo en france 24 en esta ocasión
estamos fieles a nuestra cita con los 10
deportistas del año en este 2020 de la
pandemia que ha afectado todos los
grandes calendarios deportivos de ahí la
importancia de esta selección que en
esta ocasión nos deja con muy poca
representación de deportistas de américa
latina- dado que sobre todo en esta
parte del mundo hemos tenido muy poca
actividad deportiva algo que ha llevado
a varios deportistas de la región a huir
buscando otros horizontes dedicar a su
preparación olímpica esto da seguramente
para otro especial de momento vamos a
comenzar con esta selección de 10
deportistas una selección que hacemos
aquí en la redacción de france 24 vamos
a comenzar con un hombre que ha estado
presente en todas las ediciones que
hemos hecho de estos 10 deportistas del
año aquí en france 24 en español es
luisa mente en el piloto británico de
fórmula 1 que este año volvió a dominar
el gran circo con su equipo mercedes
consiguió su séptima mundial algo que
hace unos años nos habría parecido una
verdadera locura el lo hizo en medio de
una fórmula uno que le permite a bajo
unas condiciones de competición que está
siendo dominado por este equipo alemán
vamos a comenzar este repaso sobre
figura de hamilton viendo una
comparativa sobre él y mi hija de él
schumacher el kaiser a una comparativa
odiosa pero en ese momento necesaria
porque como decimos hasta hace unos años
nos parecía imposible que alguien
pudiera igualar ese récord del mítico
piloto alemán veamos la comparativa es
en este siguiente gráfico como decimos
hamilton y mi hija de schumacher tienen
ya cada 17 mundiales en la máxima
competición del automovilismo o hamilton
además superó el récord de victorias que
tenía michael schumacher un récord que
estaba en las 91 victorias haciendo un
repaso más a fondo en lo que ha sido su
desarrollo su carrera hamilton ganó su
primer mundial con 23 años esto fue en
el año 2008 lo que hizo con el equipo
mclaren una temporada después de esa
temporada en donde peleó tanto con el
español fernando alonso
mi hija de schumacher ganó su primer
título con 25 años y esto fue en el año
1994 con el equipo benetton fort y
coincidencia los dos ganaron su séptimo
título mundial de fórmula 1 cada uno con
35 años hemos elegido a hamilton no
solamente por este desempeño enorme que
he tenido dominando
a uno sino también por su papel fuera de
las pistas este año donde hemos visto
protestas en todo el mundo en favor de
la igualdad social en contra del racismo
y sobre todo en eeuu en contra de los
abusos policiales
hamilton quiso que la fórmula 1 se
convirtiera también en una plataforma
desde el deporte en contra de estas
desigualdades sociales en contra de los
abusos policiales comenzó con un trino
en instagram con una publicación en
instagram en donde él le pedía a sus
compañeros que lo acompañarán en esta
labor de defender la igualdad social
desde ese deporte y ahora hemos visto
como siempre en todo prácticamente eso
que tenemos en imágenes después antes de
cada gran premio
ahí está tradicional protesta de la
rodilla en contra de los abusos
policiales pero vamos a dejar que sea el
propio lewis hamilton quien nos explique
cuál es su postura porque ha decidido
hacer esto qué es lo que le pide a la
fórmula1 estoy dijo en una reciente
entrevista
pacientes
y creo que este año ha habido este
despertar se ha visto por ejemplo en
nuestra industria que se habla acerca
del eslogan del fin del racismo que
ellos utilizan
la carrera es una se despertó el cambio
pero es muy importante que no sea sólo
simbolismo es importante que no sean
solamente palabras es importante que
realmente se tomen acciones para
conseguir el cambio para hacerlo un
deporte más diverso es shawn tendremos
que esperar a ver si vemos a hamilton
llegar hasta la temporada 2022 esta
temporada en donde se supone que van a
llegar los cambios que van a ser más
competitiva la fórmula1 esperamos a ver
si tendremos de nuevo quizás esa cara a
cara en una fórmula uno más competitiva
entre luisana milton y fernando alonso
caminos de deporte pasamos a otro
protagonista y hablamos ahora del
deporte rey un deporte que se vio
suspendido obviamente como todos debido
a la pandemia y que se se reanudó por
allá por el mes de mayo comenzó esa
reanudación en la bundesliga en la liga
alemana hay juega a nuestro siguiente
protagonista el polaco robert
lewandowski un hombre que es para muchos
el mejor futbolista de ese año donde el
20 con un lionel messi opacado
un cristiano ronaldo que no he tenido
los mejores desempeños en este año
elevando si tiene 32 años está en el
bayern y para hablar más acerca de su
figura y sobre todo de su desempeño en
este año vamos a ver la opinión del
informe del periodista invitado alexis
rodríguez de noticentro 1 c m
robert lewandowski el delantero polaco
del bayern múnich en esta década ha
vivido opacado por dos gigantes por dos
extraterrestres del fútbol como son
leonel messi y cristiano ronaldo pero
sin duda en la temporada 2019 2020 él
fue el que más brillo no estuvo a la
sombra de nadie y los títulos hablan por
sí solos porque el bayern munich de
lewandowski está a un título de esta
proeza que en el pasado realizó el
barcelona de guardiola el llamado
sextete al equipo bávaro solo le falta
el mundial de clubes y si vamos a hablar
de lewandowski hay que hablar de goles
de tantos campeón y goleador de la
bundesliga con 34 anotaciones en 31
partidos campeón y goleador de la copa
de alemania con seis tantos campeón y
goleador de la champions league esta
champions league en la que arrasó en la
que el bayern fue una aplanadora con 15
goles en 9 partidos siempre anotó más
goles de los partidos que terminó
jugando y si queremos analizarla
simplemente por su técnica pues podemos
decir que es un jugador rápido
inteligente que es un jugador que le
pega con derecha y con izquierda que es
uno de los mejores cabeceadores del
mundo y que en los dos últimos años le
agrego algo el tiro libre así que más
completo no puede ser es el mejor
jugador del mundo en este momento y es
un gran representante para lo que sería
la búsqueda del deportista del año en el
mundo lewandowski el mejor jugador de
europa y para muchos el mejor futbolista
desde 2020 haciendo un pequeño recuento
recordemos que en 2018 el balón de oro
fue para luka modric en este año no
tenemos balón de oro en 2019 lo gana
messi pero estamos hablando que en los
últimos tres años estamos viendo como
modelos y lewandowski se meten y que
entramos en el debate de 100 atrás ya en
los casos de la era de cristiano ronaldo
y de lionel mesi seguimos hablando de
fútbol cambiamos de protagonista es una
mujer es de francia cuando reina la
jugadora del olympique de lyon un pilar
también de la selección francesa ella
tiene 30 años ella quedó como segunda
mejor jugadora por detrás de la danesa
el hardware que en esa época ha jugado
en el wars burgo la hemos elegido a ella
como una de las deportistas del año por
sobre todo lo que está haciendo con el
olympique del león y lo que hizo este
2019 con este equipo que se sin duda
alguna los reyes o las reinas de europa
veamos en el siguiente gráfico un poco
más acerca del rendimiento que he tenido
juande en esta temporada de fútbol
femenino ella es campeona de la
champions league en esta temporada 2019
2020 por cierto también ganó la liga
también ganó la copa de francia y el
torneo de francia marcó cinco goles en
esta champions league femenina de este
año por cierto llegó a la barrera de los
cinco les controlan pick de lyon y uno
de esos tantos fue en semifinales contra
el psc haciendo un repaso más a fondo en
su carrera ha jugado en nueve de 11
finales de liga de campeones y en la
capitana del equipo desde el 2013 gran
desempeño que ha tenido one de canal sin
duda alguna una de las futbolistas que
se mantiene a pesar de su veteranía como
una de las figuras más destacadas en un
deporte que por cierto recordamos que
este año el fútbol femenino se vio más
afectado que el fútbol masculino por
ejemplo en europa solamente la liga
alemana fue la única
dentro de las grandes ligas de fútbol
femenino que se reanudó después de la
pandemia abandonamos el deporte rey
pasamos al ciclismo un deporte que ha
centrado casi toda su competición en el
tramo otoñal de europa y hablamos de
está de hipo gazzar sin primos droguett
otro esloveno hizo un gran desempeño
pero hemos elegido al jovencísimo
ciclista del emirates como uno de los
deportistas del año sobre todo por su
proeza por la manera en la que ganó ese
tour de francia al 2020 llegando
prácticamente como subcampeón a la
penúltima etapa y dando esa gran
sorpresa para hablar acerca de por qué
es tan de boga echar uno de los
deportistas del año veamos veamos el
informe la opinión de nuestro
especialista link del pitcher y desde la
ciudad de bogotá
la despo qatar es nuestro ciclista del
año 2020 el joven esloveno entró este
año en la historia del ciclismo en ganar
el título del tour de francia la carrera
ciclista más importante del mundo tal
vez para ganar entra en los libros de
historia por su edad él nació el 21 de
septiembre de 1998 en un pueblo de
eslovenia y se coronó campeón del tour
de francia a la víspera de sus 22 años
lo que significa que es el campeón del
tour más joven en más de un siglo de
competición está disponga chad también
entra en la historia por haber ganado su
título de licor de francia durante su
primera participación al igual que
leyendas del ciclismo como eddy merckx y
bernard inom también está disponga de
chad se destacó en esta edición del tour
de francia por haber ganado tres
camisetas distintas la primera la más
famosa la camiseta amarilla de líder de
la clasificación general pero también se
llevó la clasificación de mejor joven y
de la montaña hay que destacar también
el estilo y el escenario de la victoria
de tareas ponga chat que no era favorito
para este tour de francia el gran
favorito era su compatriota primos oro
gris
quizás el otro mejor ciclista del año
del año 2020 y de esta temporada tan
particular con la pandemia hasta la
penúltima etapa del tour de francia
primo sólo gris dominaba el tour de
francia cuando te dispongas a luz superó
durante la crono a la víspera de la
llegada a parís thalys ponga chat con su
estilo de siempre atacar y su
combatividad se llevó tres etapas de
este tour de francia y también llegó a
la cima de su deporte
sin duda alguna una de las victorias más
sorprendente es no solamente en este
2020 sino en la historia del deporte esa
victoria del tour de francia de lo que
nos hablaba de la que nos hablaba yo en
el puse a game tenemos aprovechar
tenemos a darren joven e poli hagan
bernal el colombiano que tripleta de
ciclistas jóvenes que seguramente van a
dar mucho de generar en el tour del 2021
que por cierto tiene menos montaña y
mucha más contra-reloj seguimos hablando
de ciclismo para hablar de nuestra
siguiente protagonista la número 5 en
esta clasificación que hacemos de los 10
deportistas del año desde país bajos
anna vanderberg en la sin duda número
uno del ciclismo quedó de menos a más en
esta temporada y para hablar de ella
vamos a la ciudad de parís con el
análisis de nuestra periodista natalia
ruiz giraldo
si este año hay una deportista que se ha
coronado de gloria esa es anna
vanderberg en la ciclista holandesa que
termina este 2020 como la número uno
según la clasificación mundial de la
unión ciclista internacional esto por
delante de la italiana elisa longo
borghini y también de su compatriota
anemia que van vloten realidad consiguió
cerca de ocho victorias dos de ellas a
comienzos de año en febrero durante la
semana ciclista valenciana justo antes
de que el coronavirus detuviera todas
las competiciones pero una vez retomó la
temporada no hubo absolutamente nada que
pudiera detenerla y prácticamente en un
espacio un poco más de un mes pues la
holandesa consiguió el resto de estos
títulos cabe notar sobre todo ese
doblete conseguido durante los mundiales
de ciclismo en imola italia allí logró
por primera vez quedarse con la prueba
de contrarreloj un título que le había
sido esquivo en cuatro ocasiones en los
que había quedado segunda y también fue
campeona mundial de ruta este doblete
solamente lo había conseguido
anteriormente la francesa jeannie longo
en 1995 vanderberg en quien también se
convirtió en la campeona europea de ruta
pues se sumó a su palmarés su victoria
en el giro rosa así como en la flecha
valona todo esto con el mismo mayor el
de bolsa
dolz mans ahora para 2021 pues madre
breguen a sus 30 años tiene un objetivo
en la mira los juegos olímpicos de tokio
allí espera volver a colgarse la presea
dorada algo que ya había logrado en río
en 2016 y luego de esto bebe como se le
conoce cariñosamente pues planea
retirarse
entramos ya en la segunda y última mitad
de este especial de los 10 deportistas
del año llevamos ya 5 no están en un
ranking especial los hemos elegido en
ranking de deportes no vamos de menos a
más no es una clasificación por decirlo
de esa manera pasamos a hablar del
baloncesto siendo de alguna de un hombre
que es uno de los deportistas del año de
la década y seguramente lo será del
siglo lebron james el jugador de
baloncesto que este año hizo lo que
prácticamente nadie ha hecho ese deporte
consiguió por tercera vez llevar a una
franquicia que no competía a llevar a
ganar el campeonato lo hizo con los
ángeles lakers lo hizo para que la
franquicia que le ponen a ganar a su en
ello número 17 y siendo además el líder
de un proyecto en el que creyó desde la
temporada pasada cuando ya estuvo
rozando llegar a los playoffs después de
muchos años de un bajo rendimiento por
parte del equipo de los lakers vamos a
ver un gráfico con algunos de los datos
de lebron james en este 2020 que
consiguió lebron con este nuevo anillo
tiene ya cuatro en ellos cuatro
campeonatos de la nba de la liga del
mejor baloncesto del mundo consiguió
además también ser por cuarta vez el
envite de las finales en lo que se
refiere a sus porcentajes en esta
temporada
y cinco años hizo un promedio de 25,3
puntos 10 2 asistencias y 7 8 rebotes y
en las finales estuvo prácticamente casi
en el triple doble en cada uno de los
partidos que consiguió un dato más
acerca de la postemporada con siguió 580
puntos y 184 asistencias
ningún otro jugador de baloncesto en la
historia de la nba con ciudad ha
conseguido estos números al igual que lo
hice mentor
lebron james también ha sido ha sido
protagonista fuera de la cancha ha sido
uno de los jugadores junto con otras
figuras como acabo el indoor quien los
tiene ha liderado esa lucha a favor de
la igualdad social contra el racismo y
para añadir añadir más mística a todo
este año de lebron james
recordemos que en enero pierde a una
leyenda de baloncesto y un amigo
personal a kobe bryant en enero casi
como a modo de homenaje para kobe él se
promete promete ganar de nuevo ese
anillo de los lakers para acabar con esa
sequía y por cierto igualar el récord
ante los boston celtics vamos a escuchar
lo que dijo lebron james por allá
entonces por el mes de enero a comienzos
de año mejor dicho cuando
acerca de lo que significaba para él
kobe bryant
bueno
sabemos que él nos está vigilando y es
nuestra responsabilidad representar el
púrpura y dorado
sino por todos los grandes por todos los
que han venido los pacers así que no
quiero quedarme sentado aquí y hablar
mucho al respecto de un tema muy
sensible pero está con nosotros cada día
declaraciones del mes de febrero
concretamente y se notaba todavía mucha
emoción en las palabras de lebron james
pasamos ahora al atletismo un deporte
que también se ha reactivado sobre todo
al final de ese tramo con más actividad
sobre todo en eeuu y en europa que no se
ha visto tan interrumpido como en otras
partes del mundo como por ejemplo aquí
en américa latina y hablamos de la
representante de nuestra región en esta
lista la venezolana
yulimar rojas quien a pesar de para la
pandemia sigue siendo sin duda alguna la
reina del triple salto y para hablar de
ella un compatriota y compañero de
nuestra redacción
nuestro compañero luis méndez que desde
la ciudad de bogotá nos da su análisis
sobre yulimar rojas
2020 marcó un año difícil para el
deporte mundial debido al brote de kobe
19 en el atletismo la situación no fue
distinta a pesar de ello yulimar rojas
logró conseguir importantes resultados
uno de ellos fue en el mitin de madrid
celebrado a principios de año y en donde
la venezolana logró marcar un nuevo
récord mundial en salto triple en pista
bajo techo con un brinco de 15.43 metros
más adelante y sobre el final de la
temporada yulimar rojas consiguió un
salto de 14 puntos 71 metros que valió
como el mejor del año 2020 todos estos
méritos le permitieron awards atletics
elegirla como la atleta del año 2020 un
premio que se suma a la elección de la
deportista más destacada en venezuela-
de este año un premio que entrega el
círculo de periodistas deportivos 2021
representa un año importante para la
carrera de rojas ya que en tokio sede de
los juegos olímpicos la venezolana
espera cumplir dos objetivos el primero
conseguir la medalla
en el salto triple el segundo lugar un
nuevo récord mundial en esta
especialidad de conseguir esos lauros el
atletismo latinoamericano estará muy
bien representado para los próximos años
sin duda dilemas la gran favorita para
conseguir ese oro y ese récord mundial
en el próximo año ese oro olímpico y
conseguir a lo largo del 2021 es el
récord que tanto quiere ella y que ella
misma ha reconocido que es lo que en
verdad la obsesiona seguimos hablando de
atletismo para hablar sin ninguna duda
de una estrella mundial que explotó en
este año 2020 nación eeuu pero es de
suecia arman su planta y un chico de
apenas 21 años que se ha configurado
como la gran estrella de este deporte
también a nivel mediático para que se
hagan una idea de este de ese personaje
tuvo 16 competiciones en este 2 en el 20
y todas las ganó además con varios
récords para explicar esos récords ya
sea en rendimiento increíble vamos a la
ciudad de caracas con el análisis de la
periodista especializada en atletismo
que umar esa
armando plantes no tiene acostumbrados a
actuaciones en los que la precocidad es
la regla como es el título mundial que
obtuvo en 2015 en el mundial menor de
cali o el hecho de haber sido el ogro
más joven de la historia en superar la
barrera a los 6 metros en pértiga con el
605 de 2018 en el europeo pero este año
ha ido mucho más allá de todo eso
aprovechó este
nuevo war in door tour el circuito
mundial de hecho que impulsa horas félix
para quebrar el récord de garrocha 616
estaba en poder de renaud lavillenie
desde 2014 y lo llego a 2017 en torno en
polonia una semana después fue de 2 618
en glasgow en ambos casos en el walk in
door tour llegó la pandemia se paró el
deporte mundial y al retorno en
sestriere quebró ya había quebrado en
dos ocasiones el récord mundial absoluto
en ambas ocasiones bajo techo pero
quedaba por ahí el récord mundial al
aire libre que tenía 26 años en el poder
de cerca y busca lo quebró en la golden
gala pietro mennea y hay que ver lo que
es la longevidad de estos récords
mundiales de garrocha nos lo dice la
juventud de este atleta de apenas 21
años recién cumplidos
formando plantes que por cierto su madre
le lleva a las pértigas por europa y el
plan de es que es también amigo de
franceses renaud lavillenie esperamos un
duelo bonito en tokio aunque parece que
el plante se está dominando con
muchísima claridad este deporte dejamos
el atletismo para entrar ahora en el
tenis con un austriaco que tiene un gran
nexo con américa la tiene que sin duda
este año se ha destacado y ha sido su
gran explosión lo hemos elegido a
dominique team ya 0 esperaban que fuera
el abdomen y tiempo encima de rafael
nadal pese que el español consiguió ese
récord de los 20 que nestlé porque
consideramos que esta explosión augura
un enorme futuro para un tenista que ya
se cuida con el denominado big trip y
para hablar de esa figura de 2015 vamos
de nuevo a la ciudad de parís con el
informe el análisis de nuestra
periodista erika olavarría
sin duda este 2020 es el año de
dominique
el joven que con apenas 23 años en el
2017 se colaba entre los cuatro mejores
tenistas del mundo ha capitalizado este
año los cambios que inició en el 2018
cuando decidió deshacerse de su técnico
histórico los tragos gunther bresnik
aquel que le llevó a desarrollar su
conocido revés a una sola mano y lo
cambiado por el chileno nicolás massú
campeón olímpico y top ten' de hecho un
mes después de contratar a más útil
ganaba su primer máster el de indian
wells y este año logró su gran sueño de
ganar un gran slam el abierto de eeuu
convirtiéndose de hecho en el primer
jugador nacido los 90 en ganar un gran
slam y también quedó finalista en el
open de australia pero sobre todo
nicolás massú ha conseguido que team que
ya era fuerte en arcilla de hecho ganó
varios partidos contra rafael nadal
sobre polvo de ladrillo si hiciera
también fuerte en las canchas dura un
requisito fundamental para ser número
uno del mundo
de hecho cuatro de los triunfos que ha
conseguido bajo la dirección del chileno
han sido sobre superficies rápidas pero
lo que más destacan en el entorno de
dominique team es el trabajo psicológico
que ha hecho el chileno la mamá de
dominique karim no puede creer que
nicolás massú sea tan positivo y es una
opinión muy importante ya que por lo que
hemos visto aquí en roland garros
el clan team es muy sólido y de hecho en
dominique suele viajar junto a sus
padres a los torneos este excelente año
ha sido solamente un poco pagado por su
nueva derrota en la final del másters de
londres esta vez frente al ruso danila
medvedev
pese a ello nicolás massú que es muy
discreto como técnico le dedicó unas
palabras en twitter lo felicito por este
gran año y le dijo te lo mereces por tu
pasión por tu esfuerzo y por tu
dedicación ahora el pupilo quiere seguir
los pasos del maestro y ha confirmado
que va a participar en los juegos
olímpicos de tokio quizás como lo hizo
nicolás massú en el 2004 se lleve el oro
pero en todo caso ha sido la experiencia
no la que lo ha convencido a dar este
paso que hasta ahora parecía descartado
de su carrera
hablamos ahora de la última seleccionada
de esta lista de esta selección de los
10 deportistas del año aquí en francés
24 es naomi osaka la tenista japonesa
ella este año haciendo un rápido
recuento de lo que ha sido su temporada
ganó el abierto de eeuu llegó hasta la
tercera ronda en australia en el open de
australia y no jugó en roland garros
pues tras un abandono ella ha sido la
figura más destacada que elegimos en
medio de una temporada muy atípica para
el tenis femenino sino una clara
dominadora sin ninguna jugadora que haya
repetido ganar ninguno de los tres grand
slam peace han jugado este año porque no
tuvimos wimbledon los recordamos al
igual que ocurre con luisa med mar al
igual que ocurre con lebron james
elegimos al saca también por su papel
fuera de las canchas ella es de japón
ella es afrodescendiente y ha denunciado
que ya ha tenido que vivir el racismo en
su propio país se ha convertido en una
importante voz también en contra de los
abusos policiales de hecho estuvo
llevando en el abierto de eeuu una serie
de tapabocas con nombres de víctimas de
abuso policial y al respecto a ella le
decían que por qué
decía apartarse de la política de opinar
más acerca del deporte ya re poder
respondió a través de un tuit sobre las
declaraciones que yo hay que refleja muy
bien esa postura que como vemos
acompañan en sus tapabocas veamos lo que
dijo entonces en ese entonces una
ominosa que con este tweet sobre si ella
debería o no hablar acerca de política
en el deporte dice naomi o saca a todas
las personas que me estuvieron diciendo
que mantuviera la política fuera del
deporte lo cual no fue del todo política
del todo político en realmente me
inspiraron a ganar madres vale creer que
voy a intentar estar en sus pantallas de
televisión durante lo más que sea
posible 23 años tienen audio saca la
décima de esta clasificación de los
deportistas del año en 2020 y así
llegamos al final de ese especial
esperamos sus reacciones sus comentarios
están de acuerdo les gustó no sé de
acuerdo con esta selección y gracias por
haber estado con nosotros en france24
quédense porque hay más en france24
france24 puntocom
[Música]